في عام ٢٠١٨،
كان نيكولاس كروز شاباً في مدرسة الثانوية
في ولاية فلوريدا،
وكان على ارتباط بمجموعة تؤمن بنظرية تفوّق العرق الأبيض،
ولأنه يمتلك أسلحة نارية في منزله،
فقد طرد من المدرسة،
وكان يشكل خطرا على زملائه من الطلاب،
وقيل إنه شارك في تدريبات شبه عسكرية،
وفي يوم من الأيام وصلت رسالة مجهولة لل FBI،
بخصوص
فيديو نشر على موقع يوتيوب
قال فيها مستخدم اسمه نيكولاس كروز
"سأصبح مطلق نار محترفا في المدارس".
وعندما لم يتعرف الFBI على هوية مرسل الرسالة،
تم تجاهلها،
حتى جاء اليوم المشهود، ففي ذلك اليوم
ذهب كروز إلى المدرسة،
وبينما كان الطلاب يستعدون للعودة إلى منازلهم،
دخل عليهم كروز وأخرج رشاشا من طراز سميث،
وأخرج بندقيته أيضا، لماذا يا ترى؟
هل يود الاستعراض أمام زملائه أم ماذا؟،
كلا! لقد أخرج رشاشه فجأة وبدأ بإطلاق النار ،
ياااا إلهي، مالذي يجري، هل نحن في حلم؟
هكذا كان الطلاب يتساءلون، لكن الحقيقة
أنه لم يكن حلما أبدا،
نعم فكروز ظل يمطرهم بالرصاص!
فمنهم حاول الاختباء وراء الطاولة
ومنهم من اقترب من الجدار،
ومنهم من احتمى بزميله والآخر احتمى بالجثث المتساقطة،
رعب ليس له مثيل في الولايات المتحدة
واجهه هؤلاء الصبية التلاميذ، فأعمارهم لم تتجاوز ال١٦ وال١٧ بعد،
لكن الموت المؤكد قد قضى على ١٧ طالبا حينها، ..
بعد هذه الحادثة بمدة قصيرة،
أعلن أن أحد الطلاب الناجين من الموت،
قد انتحر بسبب تأنيب الضمير،
فكان يقول
(كيف لي أن أنجو وقد مات زملائي أمام ناظري)،
ليس هذا فقط، قبل انتحار هذا الطالب الذي لم يذكر اسمه،
كانت التلميذة سيدني آيلو الناجية أيضا من حادثة إطلاق النار
وتبلغ 19 عاما. قد انتحرت بسبب شعورها بالذنب
لأنها نجت من المجزرة التي راح ضحيتها 17 شخصا
من زملائها في المدرسة، وقد قال والدها،
إنها كانت تعاني من أعراض اضطراب ما بعد الصدمة
ومن عقدة ذنب بسبب نجاتها فيما قضى أصدقاء لها.
بعد الحادثة، تم القبض على كروز وعندها بدأ بادعاء الجنون،
وها هو الضابط يحقق معه..
يحاول التهرب من التحقيق بقوله نسيت ولا أدري،،،
حاول كروز أن يظهر للمحقق أنه فقد قواه العقلية،
ولا يعرف شيئا، بالطبع هو يفعل ذلك لأجل أن ينجو من العقاب ويتم تخفيفه،
لكنه قد اعترف في فيديو مسجل على هاتفه،
بأنه سيقوم بهذه المجزرة وذكر عدد الضحايا في المدرسة،،
وظل فريق دفاعه منهمكا لإثبات أنه ليس بكامل قواه العقلية .
ليخفف حكم الإعدام الذي طالب به المدعي العام للولاية
على الأقل إلى السجن المؤبد، وفي النهاية فقد اعترف كروز بجريمته،
أملاً منه بأن يحكم عليه بالمؤبد لا الإعدام،،
لا تزال حالات إطلاق النار في المدارس في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
في ازدياد خصوصا في  آخر ١٠ سنوات،
حيث وصلت لقرابة ٣٠٠ حالة لتحتل المركز الأول عالميا بهذه الظاهرة،،
وصلت العنصرية أشدها في عملية كروز المناهض
لأصحاب البشرة السوداء؟
فهل كان كروز يستطيع حقا أن يمرر خدعة فقدانه لذاكرته
على ضابط التحقيق والمحكمة؟...
فضلا وليس أمرا لا تنسوا دعمنا باللايك والاشتراك
في القناة وتفعيل الجرس لنستمر بالمزيد إن شاء الله.